We have to talk about the so-called Muslim
ban today.
Before I say anything else I want to be crystal
clear on one fact: I am absolutely against
any ban on immigrants based solely on their
religion, whatever religion that may be.
I will always judge people as individuals,
not as a collective, and I certainly don't
plan on stopping now as this fight over refugees
and immigration is just heating up.
Within any group there are sub groups of people,
and often these sub groups contain the most
vulnerable populations such as free thinkers,
gays, and atheists.
Just so the trolls get it right: I, Dave Rubin,
am 100% against any blanket ban which targets
all Muslim people, and I would feel exactly
the same way if it was targeting other religion.
Now, this refugee issue is one of those topics
where, no matter what I say, I will get hate
from both the extreme left and the extreme
right.
Actually, the more I get hate from both sides
the more I realize I'm doing the right thing
because nuance, honesty and logic are lost
on those who stay on the dogmatic fringes.
So, before I share my thoughts, I think it's
important we separate some fact from fiction
and discuss what's actually in Trump's executive
order.
I've got the whole text of the order right
here and yes, I read the whole order, unlike
most of the people screaming about it online.
Despite what the hashtag on Twitter might
tell you, this is not a Muslim Ban.
First off, The word Muslim isn't in the text
of the order, not even once -- you'd think
if you were exclusively trying to ban people
of one religion from entering the country,
you'd have to cite which religion you're talking
about.
Secondly, and perhaps more importantly, the
ban doesn't include any of the five most populous
Muslim countries: Indonesia, India, Pakistan,
Bangladesh and and Nigeria.
So, if this was exclusively a Muslim ban,
it does stand to reason it would include these
countries, which adds up to roughly 750 million
people.
So if it is a Muslim ban, it's excluding more
than half of the Muslims in the world.
This doesn't mean there aren't some valid
questions about the list of which countries
are banned, as well as some glaring omissions
of this executive order.
The 7 countries listed are: Syria, Libya,
Sudan, Iran, Yemen, Somalia and Iraq.
All of these countries are involved in heavy
sectarian violence, some of which is a direct
result of American intervention, without question.
To be clear though, no major terrorist attack
has happened on American soil from anyone
from the 7 countries currently on the banned
list.
At the same time there are omissions on the
list, most notably Saudi Arabia, which 19
of the 21 9/11 hijackers were from.
The argument I've heard on this is that the
ban applies to current conflict zones, and
as odious as the Saudi government may be,
the country isn't a war zone.
I don't see how this is related to whether
extremists are coming out of the country,
actually we know they have in the past and
continue to do so, but that seems to be the
argument being made.
There are also many questions as to whether
Trump's business ties in countries like Turkey
and Saudi Arabia were at least part of the
reason that they were left off the list.
We know for a fact that Turkey is letting
ISIS fighters into Europe through it's border
and Saudi Arabia is the home to the worlds
most fervent stand of Sunni Wahhabism.
So quick recap so far, we have a ban on nationals
from countries which are currently hot beds
for terrorism, though the list is incomplete
at best and arbitrary or ill conceived at
worst.
Next is whether this is an actual ban or not.
From reading the document itself as well as
analysis from other sources I generally trust,
there is in no way this order, at the moment,
is some kind of permanent ban on the people
from the countries listed.
It's a 90 day ban on people from those 7 countries
and a total temporary stop of our refugee
admission system for 120 days so the vetting
system and other processes can be reviewed.
The one exception to this temporary stop is
for Syrian refugees, who are banned indefinitely.
Perhaps this will lead to Trump trying to
actually ban all foreign nationals from these
countries or even expanding it to other countries,
but at the moment, it is a temporary ban while
we figure out what's going on at our borders.
Simply put, whether you like it or not, this
is one of the promises Trump made.
If at the end of the 120 days we have a stronger
vetting process not based on blanket bigotry
but rather on informed decisions about each
person individually, then we can start to
have an honest discussion about how many refugees
we can or should let in.
On the extremes we now have people calling
for totally open borders which is national
suicide, and we have other people calling
for zero immigration which is the antithesis
of what America stands for.
Another important piece of the order is the
deference is being given to religious minorities
who are under persecution.
I find the anger against this quite confusing.
The left is supposed to be for minorities,
but in this case, giving priority to Yazidi,
Kurds, Christians and others who are being
wiped out as we speak, is somehow being turned
flipped as if this is supposedly anti Muslim.
The truth is these religious minorities are
the most vulnerable communities.
It doesn't matter if you're a believer or
a non believer to understand that protecting
the most at risk is the right thing to do.
An interesting point to add here is the Obama
administration let in 12,000 Muslims from
Syria in 2016, but only 100 Christian refugees.
I don't know the reasoning behind his policy,
but where was the outrage when Obama left
Christians behind, if this current outrage
truly is about protecting minorities who are
in harms way?
The order also limits the amount of refugees
to 50,000 per year which is basically in line
with where we've been over the past 15 years
or so.
For example in 2003, 2006 and 2007, we admitted
less than 50,00 refugees per year under George
W. Bush.
Obama bumped up admitted refugees to 70,000
people in the last two years of his administration,
but in the previous three years before that
he was right around 50,00 as well.
Without getting too lose in the numbers here,
the point is, Trump's proposal isn't far off
previous administrations, especially if you
remove the bump in the last two years under
Obama.
Of course you could argue American action
or inaction in Syria has led to many of these
refugees in the first place.
So again, where was the outrage when we were
dropping bombs, not just temporarily limiting
refugees.
Of course the last few years also coincide
with a jump in world wide jihad especially
in countries which have taken in many refugees.
I think if you could ask the people of Germany,
France, and Belgium if they might rethink
some of their immigration policies over the
past few years there would be a resounding
yes.
These countries now have to deal with homegrown
terror as well as the influx of refugees which
has created a new set of problems both economically
and culturally.
None of this is a reason not to let sensible
amounts of properly vetted refugees in, but
it does lend credence to a temporary pause
while we figure out if our vetting is effective
seems fairly sensible.
The rollout of the order was no doubt absolutely
chaotic and confusing but I'm not sure if
any real change to our system could be done
without a certain amount of chaos and confusion,
especially because of a media that thrives
on emotion over fact.
Finally, there also seems to be some confusion
as to whether people who currently reside
in the United States with green cards from
these 7 countries mentioned in the order would
be able to leave the country and come back.
At first it sounded like they couldn't get
back in, then it sounded like yes, now it
sounds like a case by case basis.
For example, my friend and former guest Faisal
al Mutar, who is a refugee from Iraq who now
lives in America and has devoted his lives
to fighting Islamist and for secularism, could
possibly be locked out of the country if he
was to go do a speaking gig in Canada with
my friend and former guest Ali Rizvi, a Muslim
reformer.
This portion of the order still seems to be
in flux, which is evidence of a unprepared
roll out.
Of course this is 2017 and facts seems to
take a back seat to fiction and hysteria at
every turn.
So some protesters are protesting without
really knowing what's happening.
New York Senator Chuck Schumer is crying and
talking about a Muslim ban when he knows full
well that isn't what this is.
People are now drinking more Starbucks or
boycotting Starbucks because Starbucks CEO
Howard Shultz said he would hire 10,000 refugees.
Elon Musk, who publicly offered on Twitter
to take people's concerns directly to Trump
is being attacked by people as if he's enabling
a Nazi.
As I predicted a few weeks ago, misguided
outrage is taking the place of real discussion.
So when politicians scream about a Muslim
ban, which this is not, it feeds the fire
to Trump to do whatever he wants, because
no matter what he does he knows they are going
to be outraged.
This is why the regressive left and the Trumpian
right are the match made in hell for each
other.
We have one side which refuses to debate Islamism
and immigration honestly and another side
that will be all to happy to use circumvent
our intended legislative process with the
stroke of a pen.
If you value liberty over authoritarianism,
then neither of these positions are tenable.
In an effort to make sense of some of the
madness surrounding the executive order, I
have a few interesting conversations planned
for this week, and I also want to share two
articles by people I truly respect, thought
they are often at opposite ends of the political
spectrum.
Below you can find links to an article Ben
Shapiro wrote about the order, as well as
a blog post by Sam Harris.
In addition to those sources, in case you
missed it, I did a live stream with Faisal,
who is directly affected by this order, and
you can find a link to that below as well.
And finally, my guest this week is no stranger
to controversy and also someone who often
finds himself in the crosshairs of people
on both extremes.
Glenn Beck will be joining me in studio today
to discuss refugees, Trumpism, the modern
conservative movement, online media and more.
I agree with Glenn on some issue and disagree
with him on other but generally find him to
be willing to have the hard conversations,
which right now we need more than ever.